It's also worth highlighting some readily available materials and textures that you
can use to just get started with your project.
So the starter content is the first thing to highlight here, which contains a selection
of sample meshes and assets, but also lots of materials and textures to get you started.
So whenever you create a new project in Unreal Engine from the launcher, it'll say, do you
want to include starter content?
And you can decide whether to tick that box or not tick it.
It is loaded default by most templates, but you can also add it to the project at any
time. And if you need any kind of prototyping assets to get started with, the starter content
is a really great inclusion to a project.
That being said, you know, if you don't need it, just you don't need to add it to begin
with. And if you feel like you don't need it, but then need it at a later point, very
easy to migrate into the project at any later date.
So just gives you a few tools to get started with that.
And then we also have the marketplace.
So marketplace can be found through the launcher, the Epic Games launcher.
And you can find this on the marketplace times here.
So say we wanted to add some automotive materials to our projects, we could click add to
projects and it says, you know, which project do you want to select here?
And you can add them after the fact.
So these are all commercially available data, although they do contain a lot of free
packs on there. So you can actually filter through the free content as well if you wanted
to. And you can download marketplace packs through the vault, which is down here and
access them from any system using your Epic launcher credentials.
So very nice, flexible way of working.
And especially some other people might have done a lot of groundwork that you need to
just add to your project and get going with.
Very useful for that kind of thing.
And then also Quixel Bridge.
So you can find Quixel Bridge through the content menu here and inside the editor.
And this is all free data accessible directly from the engine.
There's a whole host of high quality assets here that you can use to just get your
projects up and running. It's an enormous library of 3D assets and materials and
textures and very easy to use in your projects.
Use them effortlessly. Just drag and drop and start working with the content.
It's a really, really powerful resource there.
But some other resources if you if you wanted to search for some more.
So lots of lots of content on the Internet.
Some notable examples are Texture Haven, which a URL for is there.
You also have the free PBR website, which is also see a URL for and then Ambient CG.
In case any of those additional resources were useful to you.